salut le 15 novembre quand je vous ai
fait une vidéo sur la douleur je vous ai
proposé de parler de la méditation je
vous ai demandé votre avis vous avez été
moule de moins que bolt à dire oui donc
derrière ce titre put à cliquer se cache
une vidéo sur la méditation mais avant
de commencer je voulais revenir sur le
jeu que je vous offre pour les 200
millions abonnés le cadeau que je vous
fais j'en ai parlé dans la vidéo de
lundi et j'ai eu beaucoup de questions
par rapport à ça alors je réponds aux
questions les plus posées en trois
points premier point vous avez jusqu'à
dimanche pour vous inscrire comme ça je
laisse passer le week-end et dimanche
soir je coupe les inscriptions et on va
commencer à préparer tout pour les
envois deuxième point beaucoup se disent
ça m'a bien fait rire mais si j'en vois
une enveloppe avec ma propre adresse
l'enveloppent elle revient chez moi
c'est pas faux seins alors ce qui se
passe et que vous allez recevoir un mail
de ma part avec une petite vidéo
explicative et une adresse à cette
adresse vous allez envoyer une enveloppe
jusque là c'est clair et qu'est ce qu'il
y aura dans cette enveloppe y aura une
autre enveloppe que vous aurez préparé
avec votre adresse dessus et les timbres
d'une enveloppe format a5 que vous
plierez pourquoi pas avec votre adresse
timbrée vous la mettez dans l'autre
enveloppe que vous m'envoyez et si vous
habitez à l'étranger peu importe où
c'est pas un souci il suffit juste que
vous mettiez à ces timbres pour être sûr
que l' enveloppe va revenir il n'y a pas
un poids démentiel c'est un poids tout à
fait classique donc vous timbre et sa
comme n'importe quelle enveloppe et
troisième point pourquoi j'en vois pas
un truc par mail parce qu'il ya quelque
chose que je ne peux pas envoyer par
mail déjà et j'ai envie de faire un
cadeau à la base donc c'est un vrai truc
physique et c'est pas pour envoyer un
mail qui n'a pas de valeur c'est pour
que vous ayez vraiment du courrier avec
quelque chose dedans maintenant que tout
ça est dit génériques
cette vidéo sur la méditation mon but
c'est surtout de vous dire rapidement ce
qu'est la méditation et comment le
pratiquer c'est plutôt adressées aux
débutants alors pourquoi quand comment
combien pourquoi c'est pas compliqué
c'est pour calmer le mental justement
toute cette année sur les vidéos je vous
apprends à faire des choses avec votre
tête
elle plus vite chiant être peut-être
plus rapide en tout cas j'espère mais au
final il ya un espèce comme ça de dhimmi
nos cerveaux alors que le cerveau le
mental il faut savoir aussi le calme et
c'est très important et le but de la
méditation c'est de stopper comme ça un
flux permanent d'idées de différents
jugement que l'on porte sur soi même ou
sur ce qui nous entoure pour retrouver
n'oeuvrait perception une vraie
perception dont on n'a même plus
conscience
j'aborderai même pas le côté spirituel
de la méditation mais juste la
méditation comme étant un outil pour se
recentrer un petit peu et pour
comme je le dis c'est calme et le mental
mais quand pratiquer n'importe quand peu
importe le matin le midi le soir l'après
midi ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
combien de temps qu'une question qu'on
me pose souvent quand on sait que je
fais de la méditation combien de temps
on médite le mieux c'est comme pour tout
c'est de le faire régulièrement
donc je vous recommande de faire plutôt
dix minutes mais 10 minutes tous les
jours passent quand même dans 10 minutes
c'est rien à trouver comme en terme de
temps dans une journée on a tous dix
minutes 10 minutes au réveil par exemple
ça peut être un rituel comme ça au
réveil c'est très bien et comment alors
il ya plein de formes différentes de
méditation je vais pas vous faire les
explications là comme ça de toutes ses
formes là mais ce que je vais vous
proposer ça se rapproche plus de la
méditation en pleine conscience
c'est une méditation qui est basée sur
l'instant sur le moment présent et sur
ce que vous êtes tout d'abord vous
trouver un endroit calme où vous serez
pas déranger vous mettez tout ce qui est
téléphone etc
en mode avion vous atteignez
l'ordinateur vous débranchez la sauvette
même si vous pouvez deuxièmement vous
mettez dans une position où vous êtes à
l'aise
une des bonnes positions c'est être
assis à 90° 90° tier 1 un angle de 90
degrés au niveau des genoux et un angle
de 90 degrés le dos appuyé contre un
dossier en tout cas ne fait pas de la
méditation allongée
c'est pas quelque chose que je
recommande parce que le but n'est pas de
s'endormir croyez moi je me suis déjà
endormi plusieurs fois les yeux ouverts
ou fermés ça n'a pas d'importance il y
en a qui pratiquent les yeux mi clos et
qui regarde un petit peu le loin
tain c'est à dire ils regardent cia
devant eux sans vraiment regarder un peu
comme quand on est comme ça
personnellement je préfère le faire les
yeux fermés mais ça après c'est une
question de choix à vous de voir vous ai
fait déjà des vidéos sur le fait de
pouvoir se relaxer par la respiration ce
genre de choses donc vous avez vous
concentrer sur votre respiration comme
nous l'avons vu précédemment et vous
allez prendre conscience de tout votre
corps des orteils jusqu'à la tête mais
un par un c'est ça qui prend du temps ça
peut prendre trois quatre cinq six
minutes sur votre séance complète ça
paraît beaucoup et pourtant c'est un
processus nécessaire donc et c'est là
qu'on commence à se marrer pour se
relaxer d'abord les orteils
il faut prendre réellement conscience de
ses orteils la ressentir sentir le
contact de l'orteil contre la chaussure
par exemple contre la chaussette presse
cadets pour une pression les visualiser
vraiment prendre conscience de cet
endroit là du corps et tenté de le
détendre mentalement de se sentir
complètement apaisées à cet endroit là
et après vous allez remonter pied vous
allez faire le même travail aux
chevilles
puis au mollet au genou aux cuisses
bassin aux fesses au torse au dos aux
épaules au cou au bras poignets mains
doit tous les éléments de votre visage
jusqu'au crâne
déjà quand vous aurez fini ça vous vous
sentirez déjà mieux pour la deuxième
partie vous pouvez faire ce qu'on
appelle une méditation guidée alors
guidé par un livre audio par exemple il
ya des audio qui existe sur youtube de
méditation qui vous parle en même temps
et qui vous dit deux littéralement mais
ça peut être aussi en écoutant une
musique particulière
moi ce que je préfère sur la méditation
guidée c'est les bols tibétains une
méditation avec les bols tibétains
le mieux c'est a séquencé en réel quand
quelqu'un est en train de jouer des bols
en réel mais il existe aussi des audio
là dessus et pour les audio il ya une
application que je recommande qui est
gratuite qui s'appelle petit bambou je
crois qu'ils ont quelques cours gratuits
en fait c'est pas l'intégralité de
l'apli mais si vous n'avez jamais
pratiqué de méditation vous pouvez
commencer par cela et continuer après
vous tout seul mais ça peut vous aider
de commencer par sa part une méditation
dit et je le redis quand même ces petits
bandits et ce n'est pas un placement de
produit le but de votre méditation
ensuite et c'est de penser à rien d'être
dans l'instant alors pense à rien ça ne
se peut pas vous pouvez focaliser un
petit peu donc sur un objet ou sur une
musique comme on l'a vu et vous allez
être parasité par d'autres pensées ne
les refuse et pas il faut juste regarder
cette pensée là sans jugement sans se
dire pourquoi lary
je sens cherché à la comprendre sans
chercher à la résoudre une problématique
et vous allez voir qu'elle va s'estomper
au fur à mesure c'est un petit peu comme
un nuage
et si on regardait longtemps le nuage
paille partiraient et au fur et à mesure
il y en aura de moins en moins et vous
allez donc calmer le mental et est
pleinement conscient de l'instant
présent d'où vous aide qui vous êtes
c'est ça le but final méditer ces se
détendre c'est ne rien faire et c'est
être juste dans l'acceptation sans
jugement voilà je pense que cette vidéo
est assez longue comme ça ce sera un
espèce de master class astuces
méditation hors sujet mais pas
complètement
j'espère que ça vous servir avec ça vous
a plu si ça vous a plu comme vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce en
l'air c'est important petite info du
jour dans une heure sur la chaîne
youtube je sais pas si vous connaissez
youtube s'il ya une vidéo qui sort il
m'a demandé quelques petites choses
j'ai envoyé il en a fait un remix et je
vais découvrir ça en même temps que vous
à 18h youtube si vous avez d'autres
méthodes de méditation n'hésitez pas
également en parler dans les
commentaires et à vous répondre entre
vous pour échanger vos savoir ça c'est
toujours intéressant si ce n'est pas
déjà fait vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne avant de partir et
le mental blog c'est toujours une vidéo
par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ouais mon
gars ciao
marie